aujourd'hui nous allons vers ben ali ben
ali il enchanté grande comme un
département français
sans doute le savez vous la civilisation
valdez est une des plus raffinées 12 sur
cette île il semble que la musique
sacrée des gammes l'an traduisent à sa
canne ce temps la mélodie même de la vie
dans les bois hier dans les champs
sur les gradins et âgés ou travailler et
femmes
et des parigots
les voici ses buffles puissant
femmes leur travail est difficile ruud
est certainement très très fatigant là
bas est né à nis et eni hiver alors on
peut en quelques heures de marche voir
les différentes étapes de la culture et
de la récolte
oui vous les cultures en gradins
extrêmement jolie et c'est extrêmement
bien fait
après la riponne la culture et tout cela
en même temps
et les déchets de la récolte cette
récolte du riz font vivre dans une très
heureux sécurité les canards
les femmes de l'homme dans les visières
les hommes restent à la maison la
société balinaise et critique boorman
est une société où les hommes consacrent
leur faculté à l'art jamais pour de
l'argent mais uniquement pour leur
plaisir pour celui des dieux
les artistes bailly les ont hérité des
traditions indiennes chinoises
indonésienne et ils les maintiennent
vivante dans la sculpture l'art
décoratif et la danse avec la danse
l'art devient collectif a banni la
moindre occasion est un prétexte à la
danse de cette femme qui interprète une
chorégraphie rituel exclamant confié
demain elle redeviendra tout simplement
comme les autres sam une paysanne dans
la rizière
quant à cet enfant nos visages figés
charge et d'apprivoiser d'invisibles
diable il exécute la danse des dieux
dans laquelle le sourire est absolument
interdit mais dans quelques instants
nous nous retrouverons su nous cherchons
com si j'ose dire l'affreux jojo les
profits en train terroriser les canards
à travers le marché du village voisin au
marché les femmes s'occupent des
affaires sérieuses du ravitaillement des
achats et elles ont des soucis plein la
tête
les hommes eux se passionne vous allez
le voir pour les combats de coqs
autrefois les indonésiens s'affrontaient
volontiers entre le christ au point
aujourd'hui ils confient leur instinct
batailleur à la basse cour et les coqs
de combat sont chargés de donner et de
recevoir les coups
quant à celui ci ne se gêne pas pour
voler
la femme aux seins nus de bali inspirent
les sculptures elles et ds quotidienne
comme les dieux son compagnon de chaque
jour les balinais tisse la trame de leur
vie entre la nature le surnaturel et le
surréalisme
regardez la pureté extraordinaire de
cegid
au sommet du volcan bowling dagong le
fuji yama bani né se tient le plus
ancien temple de valley le pourra
désactiver ou le brahmanisme réuni ses
fidèles et des spectateurs vivement
intéresse il ne faut pas se fier aux
apparences
et ces cérémonies toujours à base de
danse semble incompréhensible à nos yeux
les faits pourtant en sont fort simples
les balinais vivent dans un monde
surnaturel et exécute des manifestations
collectives
régis par des traditions séculaires qui
font partie d'un grand jeu qui dure
toute la vie
le balinais ce souci pendant son
existence d'attirer la faveur des dieux
est de gagner par ces démonstrations la
neutralité bienveillante des démos et
nous assistons en ce moment où kate jack
danse de sage cérémonie d'exorcisme
c'est ici qu'intervient l'emblème de
l'indonésie de garuda venu pour sauver
diplomatiquement le prince rama du roi
des démons ravana
voilà gardon
véhiculés dans un corbillard en forme de
vache jusqu'à la tour qui fera office de
fours crématoires
ainsi sont les morts les porteurs
exécuterons tout au long du parcours de
multiples des cures pour dépister les
mauvais génies l'enterrement est un
carnaval rythmée par le gamelan scandés
par les coups de gong et la musique
claire des xylophone cette musique doit
chasser les mauvais esprits pendant
qu'on ouvre le cercueil pour le garnir
de présent de pièces de monnaie de façon
que le mort ne manque de soutiens dans
les glaces plus après nations ont lieu
le même jour ou si on expédie au pays
des yeux un grand prêtre et plusieurs
manenti eu mon dieu quand fil du voyage
la procession je mette en route vers la
mer quand elle sera pas retenu sur le
rivage les successeurs du grand prêtre
et citron les clients actuels pendant
que les familles se préparent à
disperser dans l'océan les cendres des
défunts
le moment n'a pas jugé bon d emporter
alors les saisines tout perdre
historiquement les cendres sont jetés à
la mer et les flots les emporte l'âme
définitivement libérée de toutes ses
attaches terrestre à enfin gagner le
paradis des bienheureux les balinais
sont très impressionnés par les
puissances naturelles l'eau le feu
maladie les maladies les menaces
d'épidémie aussi organise dans le temps
peut sacrer les cérémonies à caractère
religieux où se mêlent invariablement le
théâtre la danse un gramme mais vraiment
un drame va se dérouler de vendre et
principaux personnages sont le baron ben
symbole du bien et randa la veuve
sorcière effrayante et un capture du
mali qui cherchent à semer la maladie et
la mort chez les hommes pour l'instant
vous ne voyez que le deux servantes de
randa ravissante petite danseuse jantes
actuellement 15
après cet âge souvent elle se marie une
danse que jamais du jour au lendemain
elle se transforme en travailleur de
force plantes fleuries nourrissent le
port et de gels même ses racines ou
maçon ainsi le deal est rigoureux tabou
qui dirige la vieille dame de lille cela
regarde les béliers et voici le baron
zing son long corps est couvert de
cheveux de miroirs et de boules dorées
le baron de représente la vertu on
pourrait presque ironiquement en déduit
à son aspect repoussant que la veste lui
manque de séduction pour les hommes
voici le singe le singe conseiller du
baron c'est une sorte d'agent secret
d'armes lourdes n'annonce que la vertu
est menacée les forces du mal sont en
route
à leur tête marcheront gda la sorcière
rennes les esprits malfaisants la
musique signale l'arrivée les pires
catastrophes sujet de l'émotion du baron
laurie leur handball la sorcière surgi
avec sa suite un vide ne démontre-t-il
un duel acharné ce livre entre les deux
esprits randa essai de mystifier
l'esprit du bien il à vertus sont forcés
de battre en retraite hors de l'enceinte
du temple mais il envoie ses serviteurs
pour supprimer le génie malfaisant de la
vieille
baron recul les chasser
mais voilà voilà les yeux ritter
et voici chris allan essayant
d'exterminer la vieille sorcière en mode
a fait appel à ses couverts de
sorcellerie est subjugué défenseurs de
la vertu
elle n'est possède au sens sorcier
d'humour et leur jette un sort elle va
les forcer à retourner leurs poignards
contre eux meurent et les voici
maintenant entre en hurlant les yeux
révulsés nous et c'est de toute leur
force d'empêcher le triste pénétrer dans
leur poitrine
mais rassurez-vous des renforts arrivent
le barang envoyé sous presse il suffira
de lui trancher la tête pour que chacun
soit délivrée du mal les soldats du
baron rouge sont réconfortés par des
bénédictions des frets et par l'expo
retrace d'alcool de riz
c'est l'instant où tout peut être gagnée
ou perdue
il faut que la tête de l'oiseau que ce
tome tient au précédent soit fixé la
seule côte d'or voilà qui est fait
remplaçant le vent de la défaite
le baron de celui de la victoire la
rampe d'arrivée le tout pouvoir il ne
reste plus qu'à mourir
les hommes ont besoin qu'il en soit
ainsi car la lutte dessus et éternelle
pour inspirer leurs danses pour jouir du
spectacle hip hop et de la beauté